&gt;&gt; So one thing I've heard about 3 d printing or catchphrase is complexity is
free. I don't know if you want to say anything about that. [laugh] I think
that's an interesting one. It's what, what does that mean to you? &gt;&gt; So that to
me means you can get as complex as you want with an object. And you can go as
crazy as you want. I've seen people do stools that were replicated sea foam.
Because they could 3D print them, and there's no other way you could ever
manufacturer that, now you can. And, I think really what that means also is,
complexity is something that we can tend to put into something, and we tend to
make things over complicated, because now that we can. And, now's kind of the
time where the wave hits the end. Right? And you have to look back and say
again, you know, what's the best way to make this and how do you make something
that could be really complex, very simplistic, because now we have the
technology to do it and the design software is so easy. &gt;&gt; Right, right. I mean
I've heard of experiments where they'll like evolve designs and they'll say
well, now that we can build it in any shape we want, let's just start putting
out different designs and have it computer analyzed. &gt;&gt; Yeah. &gt;&gt; And see which
the best one is. &gt;&gt; Yeah. &gt;&gt; So that sounds really interesting. &gt;&gt; With 3D
printing, I mean, the future could be very, very Baroque. [laugh] ... &gt;&gt; [laugh]
&gt;&gt; You could have your face on every single object in your house if you wanted
to, ... &gt;&gt; [laugh] &gt;&gt; But that's one of those questions that keep coming up, is.
Yeah. [laugh] is how do you scale that back and say, well do I really need my
face on that door knob? Is that the best door knob there is? [laugh] You know,
to be able to grab my head. It's probably not.